an intimate spooky dinner at kindly's
house tonight how did you get here jason
oh my god
i'm just kidding you guys
look at this hand
it's definitely spooky season at kylie
jenner's house and the kardashian kids
are in the halloween spirit i love it to
celebrate the launch of her nightmare on
elm street themed cosmetics line the
beauty mogul hosted a halloween dinner
party for her family and to no surprise
she went all out for the event
kylie says we're just doing a small
little dinner
this is kylie's small little dinner
i love my sister
small dinner
kylie's sisters chloe kim and kourtney
kardashian all attended the creepy bash
with their kids as well as their mom
kris jenner and her boyfriend corey
gamble their kids were there too here's
chloe hanging with kim's daughter
eight-year-old northwest
[Music]
oh my gosh
and here's coco with north's younger
brother five-year-old saint
[Music]
but it was courtney's 11 year old son
mason disick who really understood the
assignment
oh my god
i'm just kidding you guys there's mace
dressed up as nightmare on elm street's
freddy krueger rocking the slasher's
infamous uniform including his brown and
red knit sweater complete with a tan
fedora
and get this freddie's once on-screen
rival was also technically in attendance
in the form of kylie's other half travis
scott who dressed as jason
[Music]
how did you get here jason
for the festivities kylie welcomed her
guests with a truck showcasing her
line's spooky makeup which she showed
off alongside her daughter stormy
you saw my truck
hi guys
it looks so good
i haven't been able to see it in person
hi lady
and once guests went inside they walked
straight onto elm street
[Music]
kylie's fam was treated to a mysterious
menu which included donuts with syringes
of sweet filling along with some
cocktails for the nightmare themed night
and as far as decor goes each dinner
plate had a dead red rose on top
accompanied with metal clawed brown
leather gloves something chris seemed to
enjoy
but the halloween fun did not end there
the night prior kylie and travis took
stormy to the knights of the jack
pumpkin experience to continue the
festivities and it looks like the
three-year-old had a spooky good time
[Music]
[Music]
you